What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
Today we are playing a game to 21 points with these different items.
With each point you win,
you move on to the next item.
First point is with a normal racket.
Good luck!
Thanks.
I will serve.
0-0
Sorry!
Oh yeah! Now I get to defence.
I'm stuck with my own racket!
Okay, penhold.
Easy!
You started to move me around!
Of course
It's too heavy.
And lucky again.
No surprise there
Badminton!
This is my point.
I think so too!
That was so bad!
I'm starting to feel bad about my lucky
balls.
Otto, I'm so sorry!
You are always going for the edge.
As soon as you hit it I saw the ball just coming
Coming straight to the edge!
Okay, dumbbell.
[Miikka forgot the shoe..]
Smash with the dumbbell!
I hate this ruler!
Close!
How did you play with this?
I'm tempted to eat this one
I had no chance to get that on!
No more chair for me!
This is my number 1 serve.
Finally I got something in with this fork
No! It was close.
The same spot.
This is the match we have been waiting for.
Pen vs pen.
Good feeling in the pen!
No 2-point difference.
Okay so service on the table!
Easy!
Thanks!
Nice try.
Okay so that was fun!
Then pen was maybe a bit too difficult
Yeah it was really hard
Don't forget to hit subscribe
And watch our previous video there!
Until next time!